there are all kinds of junky USB sticks
you can buy make it they all look like
this so what we're going to do here is
just cut a section off of the disk and
then put the stick inside it's exactly
the same as these I mean these are just
novelty toys let's give it a go let's
see if we can slide this in the disc
inside is getting in the way we won't be
using this again but it's just a
megabyte so really good case huh well
before we don't need that it's not going
in we have more bits and pieces inside
and we seem to have broken everything
but you see the point
you can probably fit one of these inside
anything ah I'm sure it fits like this
chicken next week we will make a
telescope to throw little sticky back
plastic and we'll go and look for that
all the ports
[Music]